i'm going to leave yous with
one final piece of advice and my advice
is
never trust the super rich
what's the first thing they do when they
get rich they buy a yacht
ever been in the yachts like being in a
two-star hotel in [ __ ] roller skates
[Applause]
the only reason anyone would want to own
a yacht
is so that they can abduct children
them into international waters
[ __ ] them and dispose of their bodies
and that's what everyone who owns a
yacht
is doing okay is doing
i don't care who it is jk rowling
i have to say for legal reasons that jk
rowling is not
[ __ ] and killing children
in international waters
to the best of my knowledge
that's what's happening out there sea
levels aren't rising
it's just the weight of dead
[ __ ] kids
the sea isn't even salty
do you know there are now hotels for the
super rich that was so exclusive
that when you phone down and ask for an
extra pillow that's actually a codeword
it's actually a code word for a
prostitute imagine that you phone down
you ask for an extra pillow
the prostitute turns up now you have two
prostitutes
and only one pillow to smother them with
talking about the magazine articles and
about and about money and stuff and i
know for uh maybe this hasn't been your
experience but for my experience
and that of many other men and women in
stand-up comedy they work for years and
years and years literally
just making pennies and then all of a
sudden you hit it big and your paychecks
increase uh enormously yeah and then is
that any kind of pressure any kind of
problem for you do you
i'm i'm i'm completely all right with
that it's
it's just it seems to have
i seem to have relaxed into it nicely
now uh
i uh it's a bit of pressure i've i
noticed that it changes you in little
ways like it's changed the way i laugh
at parties oh really i used to go
i used to go that's really funny
you know now i go oh
beautiful
have you guys heard this one
oh
you laugh that way because you know
you're wealthy is that
very wealthy and then yeah that's that's
all day today the richest man in the
world he's partnering he's the richest
man in the world is
carlos slim correct from from mexico
you never heard of him of course not i'm
not a connected guy well that's why i
just heard you you don't watch the news
so carlos slim is a terrific guy and
this guy
is working with you on aura tv he
financed it
the richest man in the world 76 billion
dollars what about this i loved liberace
with all due respect man if you kick
that guy in the ass 100 [ __ ] would fall
out
now this is not what i do on hulu no you
wouldn't do that no
no because i have respect for carlos
finn
how much money does he have i don't know
it's mostly tied up in iron
i i was taping all day oh i got you
dressed up i did the milton conference a
big michael milken conference michael
milken
i interviewed uh carlos slim and then i
interviewed him for my own show
god i'd like to meet that carlos slim
you think that could happen yeah could
you imagine
go over to the beverly hilton tonight
and he'll be there watching
paul anchor sing paul anchor
remember him sure do i remember paul
anka yeah he's still around
i wonder where a guy named carlos thin
from mexico made all his money he made
it in
in uh telecommunications he owns the
mexican phone system
and in cell phones and then he branches
out he owns saks fifth avenue
he owns he bought apple at 20.
what he bought he owns apple no he
bought apple at 20. he bought 20
a share oh yeah but he's in a lot of
things mining he's got mines
yeah he's got a lot of businesses he's a
wonderful man he's a devoted family man
he's a humble kind of guy
and he had blood thirsty
i guess you got to be a little a little
bit uh his choir
yeah 76 76 years old
billion dollars only 73. that's not too
old i think it might be
we should get together with this carlos
slim seems like a good guy i just had a
meeting with uh
some lady who said she had a lot of
money fat nancy
[Music]
and what she want to finance something
with you what does she want to do with
you uh
you know what bank called me up they're
like hi we're calling because you don't
have enough money i'm like i know
she's like sir you have insufficient
funds well it's a good way to put it too
i agree with that
i find my funds to be grossly
insufficient
thanks for calling
why are you mad at me i don't understand
what how is this something i'm doing to
you
she's like sir you only have twenty
dollars that's not enough you can't
only have twenty dollars i'm like look
i'm not being broke just to [ __ ] with
you i just really don't have
any money i'm not trying to be a dick i
just
my life is shitty
so they charged me they charged me 15
that's how much it costs to only have
twenty dollars
well here's the [ __ ] up part now i
only have five
what did i pay the twenty to the fifteen
dollars for if i don't get to have the
twenty dollars
that i paid to have i
paid the [ __ ] money where's my twenty
bucks
that's like going to the movies you pay
buy your ticket and go get the [ __ ] out
of here go home
but i paid for the move no you paid for
a ticket [ __ ] you didn't pay for
a movie
you ever have negative money that's
depressing isn't it you look at your
bank account
negative 10 that's how much i have now
negative 10
that means i don't even have no money
now
i wish i did i wish i didn't have
anything i wish i just had nothing but i
have less than that
i don't have none i have
not 10.
i can't i'm like if it's free i can't
[ __ ] afford it
somebody could come up to me take this
is free [ __ ] that costs nothing i can't
afford that that's more than i had
i gotta raise 10 bucks to be broke
that's where i'm at
that's not good that's bad
apparently some of you are in the same
[ __ ] position
how's your economy doing [ __ ]
no i'm glad you appreciate that story
not everybody appreciates that story i
told that story about a week ago in
orange county california and all these
rich [ __ ] looking at me with
their boat hands and their
golf shirts and penny loafers
they're all looking at me like well yeah
like
you were financially irresponsible you
had to pay the price i don't frankly
see what you're angry about
the bank has a right to accrue a fee
clearly
that's how different it is to be rich
than it is to be poor because when
you're rich the bank pays you for being
rich
if you have a lot of money they give you
money because you have
a lot of money they say you have so much
money
that we should give you some because you
have a lot you should have more
here take more money take this guy's 15
[ __ ] him you should have it
makes perfect sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so anyways i'm down in uh i'm down in
nantucket
and uh with all family friends extended
family and all that type of stuff
nieces nephews the whole nine yards
drinking again oh baby i'm drinking
again you know i'm down there boozing it
up drinking some of that cisco brewery
whale tail pale ale whatever they got
down there
you know i got my little nantucket red
[ __ ] um
i'm friends with the banker shorts on
i'm living the dream
all right and i'm just sitting there
walking around and i'm looking at all
these rich [ __ ] people
and i just find myself i [ __ ]
the level with which i was judging them
which of course no one would give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean if i was judging
uh you know a a a
a a a a what the [ __ ] am i doing if i
was judging like you know some poor
group of people like that i would be
considered
the biggest douche ever all right you
don't know these poor people why why are
you judging them that way right
but you you do you why am i stuttering
you [ __ ]
judge rich people that way everybody
laughs they all think it's funny
you know i had to work the whole week
it's like why do i hate that guy how do
i know
he didn't get his money legitimately why
am i immediately assuming
that this guy was a complete piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know you know what it is i don't
like how rich people carry themselves
people born into wealth they just have
this like that time when i was in dc
and that little [ __ ] six-year-old kid
got up
went walked right up to the bar got
climbed up on the stool and started
calling out to this adult behind the bar
sir
sir excuse me sir like the co
i can i'll never be able to do the
proper read of that the way this kid
said it
there was such a comfort
in in in summoning this person over to
come and talk to him
to do whatever the [ __ ] he needed him to
do at six years old
um it [ __ ] annoys the [ __ ] i mean i
was just looking at
these [ __ ] rich people they have the
creepiest looking goddamn kids you ever
seen in your life
just creepy little [ __ ] future
bankers ceo looking kids
you know little blonde hair they already
got those chubby [ __ ] you know all
kids have chubby cheeks but just the way
they look
that waspy pedigree right
which is another thing i can get away
with you know what i mean
the waspy pedigree everybody will laugh
because no one gives a [ __ ] about that
you can trash
waspy people up and down i can't be
honest with this this this
jewish kind of blah blah that's it i
gotta [ __ ] apology waspi
totally gets a [ __ ] open lane
so anyways waspy [ __ ] look about them
right with their [ __ ] you know
oh they look like little winston
churchills
like they still talk like little kids
but they should be walking around here
we shall never surrender they just look
like they're gonna [ __ ]
get they're going to get some great
[ __ ] job and then they're going to
steal from the company and when they get
caught
they're not going to get [ __ ]
prosecuted just like these goddamn
bankers
just like all these rich [ __ ] they're
just not going to because they're going
to have connections
and he's he's gonna know [ __ ] about
people whatever and they just they just
hook each other up
the same way at the level that i grew up
you didn't rat out your friends they're
doing the same thing at their level
except what they can do
affects the entire population as opposed
to the level that i came up with where
you know
maybe somebody's car that used to be
there isn't there anymore
you know that's insurance fraud i guess
that hopes
that hurts the group after a while
doesn't it
i don't know so that was basically uh
what i had to work at you know and they
had this place down the street called
the summer house
i was staying out and sconced it and
it's absolutely [ __ ] beautiful and uh
i i just couldn't get myself to go in
there
i wanted to go in there i wanted to sit
down and have a [ __ ] drink but every
time i saw
another person going in with their
[ __ ] boat shoes without any socks on
like i felt like this this hatred coming
up in me
and i justified it for like two three
days and i was just like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me
you know i bet you know
those people that they're probably just
like me
or the people i hang out with in that
as i always say most of them are douche
bags but there's going to be like four
or five people in there gonna be really
interesting
i would tell you time i flew on the
plane right i sat next to that guy
who made a ton of [ __ ] money starting
his own credit card
and then he parlayed that money into
buying cell phone towers
the guy was [ __ ] hilarious he had it
lost it had it all again lost it and
then now he was on top again he had this
hey what the [ __ ] you going to do vibe
self-made man so i'm thinking they're
going they're not all like that but they
all had that same
[ __ ] i their foot their [ __ ] feet i
can't stand them
i really got issues because here i am
i'm down there i'm vacationing two
acting like oh oh but i'm the
down-to-earth douchebag with my salmon
colored shorts on
[ __ ] hypocrite
i don't know so anyways i ended up going
out fishing
uh with my family we had a great time
didn't catch [ __ ] just caught blue fish
didn't even catch a striper
didn't catch anything but you know it
was still cool
and we didn't take more than than we
were going to eat so uh i didn't feel
too bad about that but uh
i think i kind of got talked into doing
something really stupid the guy who had
the boat actually had a [ __ ] shark
cage
and he's like you know it's totally safe
we take you about 15 miles out we chum
the water
and you get in this [ __ ] cage and you
know what
ah after all these years of doing bits
about how [ __ ] stupid it is to swim
in the ocean and all that type of [ __ ]
i'm gonna do it next year i'm gonna do
it
i almost said it costs an arm and a leg
there's your [ __ ] pun right there
you're awful joke but uh it does
it's really expensive but i want to see
a [ __ ] shark
you know and i got that white thing in
me where i
uh that white person thing where i want
to see
the shark being a shark you know the
same way
i don't want to see a bear just walking
through the forest
i want to throw something at it so it
gets up on its hind leg
and starts doing that [ __ ] like it's
about ready to step into the squared
circle right i think that that is
uniquely a white thing
that we we just we just want to see an
animal
looking like it's going to kill us or we
don't feel like
that we got the full experience